have you ever missed a day no I have not
missed a day and so here's uploading
every single day you've never missed
I didn't one do not believe I have
missed a day so do you think you can
make a pretty sweet-looking render in
the same amount of time it takes people
to make something yeah guess who's
coming over today clothes peoples come
into their office today you guys don't
know people is I mean he's one of the
most prolific digital artists of our
time why it's because for every single
day for the last 12 years he has posted
and rendered some of the coolest
abstract art and posted it to his
Instagram well they just Instagram
because he's been posting since before
Instagram was a thing see this is the
thing I'm so young that I wasn't even
around when he was posting on these
other platforms deviantART maybe but
that's when he started posting pictures
she's posted so many pictures that if
you were to print out every single
picture lay it across the ocean you can
you could walk to Hawaii it's true hey
Siri how many days is 12 and a half
years four thousand five hundred and
sixty five so four and a half that's a
lot of renders four and a half thousand
pictures this guy has made every single
day for twelve and a half non-stop years
apparently he hasn't missed a day and
apparently he doesn't have backlogs
apparently he makes each one the day
it's posted one last time you guys have
done something every day consistently
for the last month the point is today is
special because he's going to come to
our studio and make one of his cool
pictures wait wait wait hold on that
actually the opposite of special because
he's made so many that it doesn't matter
do I have so many I have so many
questions to him like right you what's
your asset manager like what's your
what's your content browser look like in
cinema 4d is probably curated like the
most perfect library of assets yes use
in pretty much every photo he ever makes
he's figured out a way to put in the
least amount of effort to output the
maximum picture maximum quality input
and yeah
he's a min put max put tie guy you know
like he's figured it out so do you think
you can make a pretty sweet-looking
render in the same amount of time it
takes people to make something yeah I
could I could probably make something
pretty sweet maybe maybe not some people
quality but I could render a sphere in a
foggy room in 45 minutes guaranteed
guaranteed what if like we each sat down
and just try to do our own I think we
would all make something really cool in
the time we have but I would love to see
how much better his is I just want to
see like what is his mentality behind
like making something because you know
you only have a certain amount of time
because otherwise you would just burn
out so you have to do it really quickly
and efficiently right yeah yeah he
actually should be here any minute I've
looked up to him for a while so it's
gonna be an honor to have him in the
office in the same amount of time that
he's working on his every day we are
going to compete and see if we can make
one in the same amount of time what he
doesn't know though is that I've got a
button that that will randomly turn off
his computer giving us an advantage I
have a button that will actually like
open up a gap in the floor and drop the
seat into a pit so if like climb that go
he doesn't know about this at all we
decided to Shanghai Amana honors our
boat peoples here right now why are
these guys playing Smash Bros we got a
people
like YouTube crew in America six people
that have 400 gone how much time like
how much like captain do you guys like
uploading like per week roughly we put
out 30 minutes of polished content last
week and that's about our average yeah
so like 2 to 3 videos like key on all
things trick me just holy trick so I do
have like a hard deadline to this and I
usually I don't go like 2 minutes to
midnight but it's like literally I have
to like do nothing but focus on this
that actually happens quite often where
have you ever missed a day no I have not
miss a day and uploading every single
day you've never missed
I even one do not believe I have missed
a day oh my god yeah yeah yeah do you
ever do ever stock up on that's every
single day no no no there's definitely
no stocking up like it's definitely done
that day and posted someplace by
midnight and some one place by midnight
so we will each have 45 minutes to
create own little work of art if my can
do it we can do it but we're going to
only work with a small asset pack which
is a collection of 3d models from our
own server it'll definitely push us to
use our creativity in the most amount of
ways since when we got so many objects
to work with here other than that we're
gonna be able to use whatever we want
inside the programs here using cinema
octane and so on and so forth wait
any ideas it's a little an idea to be in
my brain my ideas let that happen I put
a giant tarp over my computer's art
isn't a competition it's a collaboration
work on my screen these guys and copy my
style but I had an idea many times I
know I'm just thinking dude I'm just
being I'm a creative person I just think
about stuff all the time
get out my strat I'm just gonna take one
of those 3d models and a blind abstract
material to it juxtapose the nature of
industrialization with I don't manatee I
know Sam that he's gonna take the
motherboards model and he's gonna take
like the cell phone tower model and you
scatter on the motherboard and call it a
day oh so that's where ideas come from
done and posted by the time this goes
off
Yes Mother composer this is it every day
no sir stop crying what are you five
minutes and then we're posting okay
there we go
44 minutes in 30 seconds oh boy okay I
made a plane people happen to return I
do this Scott you real I got your real
friends in there
they're already from the beat himself
they have 38 minutes left to finish
render and post daily follow it's going
my octane scatter is not working well
that worked don't that that work it's
already been a full 5 minutes and it's
real quiet up in here hasn't been this
quiet in this together playing goddamn
monkey balls or something yeah super
monkey ball during the super monkey ball
matches if I wear a blue color shirt cuz
I swear that much
[Music]
you know how these guys they're always
all about art okay that's all they ever
want to do is just make art they brought
in this guy the thing is everyone in the
studio looks at me as like just do the
sponsorship segments and leave us
artists to do our job well guess what
today well today is no different this
video is sponsored by Squarespace but
while I'm doing this segment I'm gonna
beat them at their own game art all
right in order to become an artist it's
real simple
Jake you only have 45 minutes you don't
worry don't worry
color contrast canvas it's pretty much
it okay so let's get started now because
today's episode is brought to you by
Squarespace the piece that I'm gonna
make is gonna be inspired by Squarespace
now first things first guys Squarespace
is beautiful award-winning templates
mean that whether you're an artist like
me or you're a musician or you're an
online store you've got access to make
one of the best websites people are
gonna see with Squarespace okay now that
I've made the square I'm just gonna clip
the edges and then that it'll look like
a ticket the next thing I need to do is
show how Squarespace allows you
simultaneous posting from your website
to your social media profiles like
Twitter and Facebook I'm gonna put a
gradient background behind my admin one
ticket in order to represent that
symmetry and that perfect balance the
next thing I need to talk about are the
traffic overviews that Squarespace
allows you to view I think the perfect
thing to represent that is just the
classic artistic image of the all-seeing
eye
the final thing that I really need to
add into this piece here is this idea of
multiple contributors and
personalization with Squarespace you see
here's Jake with his personalized
website but it's also pointed to the
all-seeing eye because he can allow
multiple other people to contribute
that's about it guys I'm gonna render
this out and if you guys are interested
in creating your own awesome website go
to squarespace.com slash corridor crew
and you'll get 10% off your first
purchase okay the final render is done
let's check it out you know I I think
that the metaphors here are so high
concept that it might be a little bit
difficult for the guys to understand
yeah this is really probably I'll save
this one maybe I'll show maybe like
maybe when he leaves I'll shove it I've
never felt fear like this before
I'm just trying to mark direct this but
I got I got the final vibe in my head I
just need to just need to execute all
right I just read over some simple
composition and symbology here just try
to make something kind of cool and makes
it go Oh neat it's cool you put them
together like that and that's gonna be
extended my project
are you feeling it 2/3 of the way done I
feel pretty good I got my direction I
got my vibe I just need to add some
stuff and dude got a post-it man got a
pretty pose you see how everybody else
is different
2850 feeling mildly confident consuming
me right now everybody's really focused
right now the man himself how you can
arable terrible who's a god-awful pile
of garbage
everyone seems to focus right now like
legit gonna be a total pilot do you
usually go into your compositions with
some sort of idea
yeah usually like look around and get
like some sort of like concept of what
I'm gonna do so not knowing anything of
what these assets are that is not you
know how I like normally work and
whatever but I think it's fun to like
try things like this once in a while
because just fun and like it helps you
to not always take every piece of art so
seriously that it just can just be like
a fun good thing it doesn't have to be
this big scary thing that you know
you're intimidated to create this is
absolute garbage being able to do this
well because I'm just [ __ ] spending
45 minutes on it yeah that's the thing I
think people's expectations are too high
it's like okay I don't know what you
expected like in 45 minutes you're gonna
come up with this just amazing
thing I mean maybe these guys will start
crying what's up that kid Dylan isn't
pretty sweet now I think just kind of
like taking your like expectations down
to kind of a realistic level for for
something that you're spending a small
amount of time on each day is the only
way that you'll like keep up with it I
can assure you of that I always had the
mindset that this was like each day is
one piece so this picture that I'm
making is one right now one force
thousand of the project so that's in
some ways how much I care about it
because I look at the project is like
the everydays it's a weird mix of like
not giving it but also super caring to
continue like to do it kids look sweet
okay new direction copying this guy
Japanese caffeine gum son keeps me going
in the competition
I didn't she just used my brain
hopefully my simulation ends before the
timers okay this is serious business
final stretch here I just the red buff
to render out getting my fog right and
I'm about to render out yeah not good
terrible Tara what stage did you say
you're at right now they'll fail stage
fail just under 14 Gary man I think I'm
just gonna let this render out let's do
it
home stretch baby home stretch I know we
won't save any winder hopefully it
renders out okay I'm stepping away I'm
making no further changes of this but I
gotta let it render out and get my axe
out ready I'm shakin 30 minutes 45 I'm
just on the hashtags 2 minutes 40
seconds a hashtags let's go you ready to
email this to myself quite quick render
with the W that's actually very good
yeah oh my god I can't hear that started
that's what we agreed to you just agreed
to 12 years
twelve years an artist will see yours
last all right this one was the one I
did nice nice work are those just
cylinders with an emission texture on it
yeah I did that same thing yeah that's
awesome you know I read some things
basically the exact same thing is Sam
does like hearts around hearts that's
the best I could do is that you getting
shot with a laser the photo scan of me
in the mix no and got like a running
pose out of it yeah the Irish mist that
you were once lost in I know I don't
know I put a motherboard in you're like
you didn't use the heart this is a mixup
on it you know like everyone like some
like techno like thing and then it was
just like we have time to actually like
sort of make it good or make sense what
it is dawn done doing anything is better
than nothing
I mean having that like 45 minute like
limit really just made you focus on like
all right don't worry about anything
ambitious yeah it's like
can I just get out there yeah yeah yeah
I think it's just like really dialing
the expectations to like how much time
did you actually put on this what do you
really expect the end piece to be like
45 minutes to me is a sketch dude like
what you made what you made what you
made they're all awesome like I'm
legitimately impressed thank you for
giving us this experience and insight
into your philosophy that's super cool
yeah thank you guys like this place is
insane you got a you got a stockpile
there just amazing what you guys have
like built like super super appreciate
the opportunity like I'm still jazz you
guys are a day mm sorry to beyond this
so follow follow Mike at people
underscore crap on Instagram it's a
great handle I think it's just people on
Twitter right yeah yeah on Twitter it's
just people thank you guys my takeaway
is that when you do something every day
for 12 years really really counts toward
something you know I think he really
proved a point which is he's able to
accomplish way way more in 45 minutes
than what we can the big thing is take
away from Mike's visit here is that it
doesn't have to be perfect just make it
just go to make it every ask us like
what do I need to start making movies
what camera gear do I need is like you
have a phone just just go do it the best
works of art were created with a pen and
paper I'll go do it go get your message
out there